[موسيقى]
يستمر السكان الأجانب في الانتقال إلى المناطق الحضرية
حيث توجد حلول مبتكرة متميزة لدعم
النمو المستمر في الخليج. أنا هنا في
غرب لندن لزيارة نادي غولف حيث
يتم استخدام التكنولوجيا لجعل
اللعبة أكثر سهولة  واحدة من
أكبر المدن في العالم
نادي تشيلسي للجولف هو موطن لأربعة
ملاعب محاكاة رياضية تسمح
للأعضاء باللعب في مئات من أفضل الدورات في العالم
تحت سقف واحد منخفض هيرمان هو
محترف سابق تنافس في
الجولة الأوروبية للسيدات وهو الآن المدير العام
نحن هنا نادي غولف على عتبة داركم ،
وهكذا أصبح من المؤكد أنه أصبح
متاحًا للناس في لندن ،
كل ما تحتاجه هنا حتى تتمكن من
التدرب على لعب معظم ملاعب الجولف
في العالم على trackman
والاستمتاع قليلاً بالبرنامج  يوجد داخل
كل جهاز تعقب عبارة عن تكيف متطور بشكل لا يصدق
للتكنولوجيا العسكرية المتطورة ، وقد تم تأسيس الشركة في
الدنمارك من قبل كلاوس ومورتون إلدروب
جور  جينسن ومهندس الرادار فريدريك
توكسون فريدريك كبير موظفي التكنولوجيا لدينا الذي اعتاد
العمل في صواريخ التتبع العسكرية الدنماركية
باستخدام الرادار ،
لذلك قال كلاوس لفريدريك هل
تعتقد أنه يمكنك تتبع كرة الجولف وكانت
هذه هي الفكرة من وراء
الشاشات الأجنبية التي يستخدمها رجل الجنزير الآن  تقريبًا جميع
اللاعبين الكبار في اللعبة ، ولكن مع توفر
أكثر من 30 نقطة بيانات للمستخدمين ،
هناك خطر الانغماس
في الأرقام التي أوصي بها دائمًا
لأي شخص يستخدمها ، استخدم البيانات
بحكمة إذا كنت تبحث عن المزيد  من 10
أرقام ،
لن تسبب لك الصداع فحسب ، بل
ستدمر جلسة التدريب الخاصة بك
إذا نظرت إلى المدربين الذين يدربون اللاعبين ،
فمن المحتمل أن تبحث في جزء من
مسار النادي قليلاً من بيانات الوجه.  تخبرك بيانات
النادي والتسديدة التي ضربتها بالنادي
عن سبب قيام كرة الجولف
بما قامت به
بينما ساعدت تقنية تتبع الكرة
في إحداث ثورة في التدريب في السنوات
الأخيرة ، ولم ينته تأثيرها على اللعبة.
هناك في عام 2006 ، اخترع Daniel forsgren في السويد
تقنية سمحت
للأشخاص برؤية المزيد على شاشة التلفزيون
باستخدام كاميرتين مقترنتين معًا ،
يستطيع Top Tracer تتبع مسار
كرة الجولف بالكامل بدقة ثم
إضافة أثر إلى الشاشة بكل
بساطة  لقد أدى مفهوم القدرة على
رؤية الكرة على الشاشة إلى
تغيير تجربة مشاهدة لعبة الجولف إلى الأبد ، وهو
ما نعيش من أجله هو جعل الناس
يضربون المزيد من كرات الجولف إذا ضربوا المزيد من
كرات الجولف ، فيمكنهم اللعب بشكل أفضل إذا كان
بإمكانهم اللعب بشكل أفضل يمكنهم الاستمتاع بمزيد من المرح
و  من خلال التكنولوجيا نقوم بتمكين
ذلك